hello
do you work here
guilty
hey you this netflix series has given us
goosebumps and potentially trust issues
but the behind the scenes of you is
nothing like joe goldberg has shown us
before you'd usually expect that the
main character of a hit television
series would put in the most work on set
but it turns out penn badgley was given
a pretty easy ride he barely had to
remember any lines i do nothing but look
up and the entire crew behind the camera
goes oh whoa man that is phenomenal that
is so creepy that's and i did nothing if
you pay attention you'll notice that
most of joe's dialogue happens inside of
his head meaning pen was able to read
off of the script the entire time
netflix even made an entire compilation
about it
is that your speechless this was
ironically perfect for penn because
while you may know him best for his role
as dan in gossip girl penn started his
acting career as a voice actor for
nintendo
but penn did still have the challenge of
silent acting where he had to make sure
he accurately portrayed the
my
voice-overs
it's a boy
ironically despite how good pen is at
playing creepy he had major doubts about
taking on the role of joe goldberg and
seriously considered turning it down so
much so that showrunner greg berlanti
had an entirely different actor in mind
for the role penn was hesitant to jump
into another high-profile tv role after
his time on gossip girl and was also
morally conflicted about who joe was as
a character but he decided to give it a
go in the end and look where that took
him i struggled greatly with the the
conflict of playing such a guy unlike
penn actress shalita did have some
trouble bringing to life her character
sherry in season 3 because of one
specific set joe's glass case when her
character was captured and stuck inside
his cage shalita said the small space
that was also packed with cameras and
the crew was just too much
she even went as far as saying that it
was her least favorite part about
filming the season because of her
claustrophobia i don't like being in
confined spaces with other humans her
co-star travis van winkle didn't make
the experience any better i don't like
being in tight spaces and god i love
travis but i also don't love being in
tight spaces with other people it was
super uncomfortable while shelita needed
time to mentally prepare herself for her
cage scenes victoria pedretti went into
almost all of her season 3 stunts
without any prep believe it or not she
actually did the majority of her stunts
and physical altercations herself but
she was such a pro that she only needed
short consultations and rehearsals on
the day of shooting if we were working
with props lifting things digging we
would just practice that day to make it
look as good as possible
but one thing the cast did have to prep
for while shooting season 1 of the
series was the hashtag metoo movement
during season 1 the movement was just
coming to light and dominating the media
this made both elizabeth lail and penn
very conscious of what their characters
were saying and even posting on their
social media accounts
the two actors would have conversations
with one another before scenes to make
sure that they were on the same page
when it came to being aware and mindful
of the outside world penn and i were
just always communicated about our fears
and doubts and insecurities but despite
all of the stressful moments the cast of
all seasons of the series was always
able to have fun on set from filming
silly social media videos to pulling
pranks on one another if there was one
thing that isn't lacking on the set of
the series it's love
while joe was having a big
transformation himself throughout season
3 of the series on screen travis was
having a transformation of his own
off-screen in order to portray kerry
properly travis had to put in the work
to look like that stereotypical
california gym head he put on 10 pounds
of muscle that required him to work out
five days a week and consult with a
nutritionist in the end it even allowed
him to do some of his own stunts i built
physicality with carrie that allowed me
to play in all of these different fight
scenes and these sequences while penn
may be friendly and warm off-screen he
definitely scared some of the cast who
were working with him while he was in
character as joe especially shay
mitchell in season one the actress loved
playing peach but just couldn't get over
one creepy scene that she had to film
with pen every single time i see that
scene i just get chills like it's the
creepiest thing ever it was the moment
where both joe and peach are watching
beck in the bathtub
chills
victoria padretti also had her fair
share of disturbing moments to film for
the series but there was one in
particular she couldn't shake it was an
intimate scene between her character
love and joe that let's just say ended a
little too quickly the actress just
couldn't get over how unrealistic it was
i found that really disturbing i was
like how are we that's not real despite
some of the scenes being not so safe
behind the scenes they took every
precaution necessary for instance the
subway tracks seen in season 1 involving
beck and joe was only shot after
elizabeth and penn took an eight-hour
safety course this intense training got
them certified to work on subway tracks
for a year and a half we can't help but
wonder if the certification was ever
used after filming wrapped pen elizabeth
with a show titled you you can bet that
the word would be used throughout the
script but we weren't prepared for just
how many times it was actually used the
official netflix instagram account came
in clutch with the exact amount in just
the first two seasons the word you was
used
3857 times while we don't have an
official count for the later seasons
we're going to bet that the word love
became a pretty big rival love love love
love love
love love while a lot of the series is
filmed in studios there are a couple of
iconic locations you can visit to get
your dose of joe goldberg the bookstore
he runs in season 1 is an actual
storefront you can visit in new york
city mooney's is actually called logo's
bookstore in real life however the
inside doesn't look the same while you
can browse the inside they built the
interior in the studio so that they'd
have more versatility and flexibility
with filming
in the u universe kovid 19 is already
finished but in the real world it was
still very much happening while filming
season 3. this meant that they had to
get creative with the script but had to
make sure it wasn't super obvious to the
audience so to get around the
restriction of large crowds they would
have the actors share their dialogue
before large events instead of at them
there's still exciting scenes that
express that like a party is happening
but maybe they showed up a little early
for the party so everyone's not there
yet because that was too many people to
have on set that day
there are many more strange aspects to
characters forty and love besides their
names but the story behind how the
characters got their titles is pretty
significant not only are they both
points in a tennis match alluding to
their wealthy upbringing and love for
the sport love means 0 and 40 means 40.
this was done on purpose to reinstate
the inequality love faces growing up
within her family forty was always worth
more than his twin she couldn't win the
television series has more or less
stayed pretty close to the storyline of
the books they're based on except for
these two characters paco and ellie it
may be shocking to hear they aren't a
part of the original story because of
how significant their characters are but
they're 100
only in the tv show the showrunners
needed a way to depict joe's love for
protecting children because of his own
dramatic childhood they did this through
both paco and ellie in seasons one and
two the most amazing part of the behind
the scenes is that you didn't premiere
on netflix and was almost cancelled when
it didn't garner an audience on showtime
if netflix hadn't swooped in and saved
the day by purchasing the rights who
knows what would have happened to the
world of joe goldberg what is your
favorite behind-the-scenes moment let us
know below thanks for watching